y'all watch this so i can seamlessly
move my cursor from this imac over to
this macbook and then over to my ipad no
it's not a magic trick but it certainly
feels like one it's actually apple's
latest wizardry which i got to test out
for a couple of weeks before it launched
now with apple's latest software updates
ipad os 15.4 and mac os moderate 12.3
you can do it too but only if you have
the right gear apple cause it universal
control if you haven't heard of the
feature or haven't tried it i'll tell
you everything you need to know i'm also
going to explain how this machine magic
works to keep people inside of apple's
wild garden of products and services
with universal control you can now use a
single mouse and keyboard to move
between your mac and ipad apple first
teased universal control at its
developers conference in 2021 and
basically it allows you to make
connections between devices without
using any wires but the name is a bit
misleading because it's not actually
universal apple tucked it inside a new
software update solely for macs and
ipads not iphones however it's still
pretty useful for helping you streamline
your productivity allowing you to shift
content between multiple devices using
one mouse or a trackpad i can use my
imac's magic keyboard as a keyboard for
my ipad without really needing to change
anything and i can use one mouse to
control all the devices too notice how
the pointer on my computer turns into a
little circle on my ipad and there's a
lot to like about it with an open
highway between your mac and your ipad
you can drag and drop files you can copy
and paste text from one device to
another you can also use three finger
gestures on your track pad to switch
between apps on your ipad and if you're
like me and hate typing on an ipad
universal control makes that a lot more
natural feeling too especially for long
documents since you can use your mac's
keyboard to type on your ipad and it's a
two-way street since you can doodle and
paint on your ipad using the apple
pencil and drag and drop those files
right onto your mac the first time i
used it it just kind of happened it
actually took me by surprise it's as if
my ipad knew it was next to my mac
actually that's exactly what happened
there are some things to keep in mind
though first you have to make sure all
your devices are signed into the same
icloud account have bluetooth turned on
and are connected to the same wi-fi
network they also have to be within 30
feet of one another and unlocked the
biggest key of all is that a mac has to
be in the driver's seat acting like a
central hub you can't use it with just
ipads but if you have a mac desktop or
laptop you can use those with up to two
ipads also universal control doesn't
work on all ipads and macs so why did
apple do this well you might have
noticed that your devices are
cooperating more and more as time goes
on you probably take for granted that
you can pick up your messages on any of
apple's devices your safari browser can
now surface what you were looking at on
your phone airdrop first let you share
content between devices in 2011 and by
2019 sidecar let you turn your ipad into
an external monitor that made multiple
devices feel more like one and now
universal control is picking up where
that left off that's a quick look at
universal control on mac os monterey
sure each of these is time saving and
shows apple's key advantage over its
rivals apple controls most of its
hardware and software ecosystem but each
of these releases also makes it harder
to exit apple's wild garden now that
universal control will let more of your
apple devices speak to each other more
harmoniously you're probably less likely
to go out and buy a chromebook or
windows laptop since those devices
aren't compatible with apple software
but that's the trade-off with apple's
magic sure you get something useful that
seems like it should have always been
there
but only if you keep buying stuff
emblazoned with this logo
if you want to know more about the
latest tech or how any of it works
subscribe to my channel and leave a
comment below letting me know what you
think i should look into next we'll talk
soon